whether you model and analyze data are
in the artificial intelligence and
machine learning industry or are simply
interested in the world of AI and ml
learn how to implement end-to-end
machine learning models and how to
deploy the latest AI tools to power your
applications with the Google Cloud
machine learning and artificial
intelligence learning path
this learning path was designed to guide
you no matter where you are in your
Learning Journey
start at the first stop if you're new to
Google Cloud
or jump in at a different stop if you're
enhancing an existing skill set
along the way earn skill Badges and
prepare to become Google Cloud certified
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of machine learning and
Big Data as well as contact center AI if
you're interested in a software-based
customer service system
learn from Google Cloud experts via
instructor-led training or take
advantage of the flexibility of
on-demand the choice is completely up to
you
Google Cloud offers multiple modalities
so you can learn how you want to whether
on demand or instructor-led you will
gain access to the same course content
in Labs so you won't miss out on a
hands-on experience
practice what you've learned in a
Hands-On immersive Advanced Solutions
Lab at a dedicated collaborative space
on google campus
alternatively take a series of on-demand
training sessions to polish your
tensorflow Ops and pipeline skills
no matter which route you choose you can
earn skill badges to show the world that
you and your team can Implement and
deploy Ai and ml Solutions on Google
Cloud
use skill badges to gain recognition or
to help you land a new role
next up it's time to prepare to become
Google Cloud certified by checking out
the various guides and Sample exam
questions
once you pass the exam you're officially
a certified machine learning engineer on
Google Cloud
looking to continue learning or for a
different topic area Google Cloud offers
learning paths spanning across the
solution pillars from beginner to
Advanced this comprehensive learning
path will guide you along your Google
Cloud machine learning and artificial
intelligence Learning Journey
time to get started